let's talk about the uh the story you
just broke yeah and uh you know in
talking about the censorship now so you
guys just put out this tweet mark
zuckerberg uh actually i have the tweet
right here you tweeted
ceo mark zuckerberg takes anti-vex
stance in violation of his own
platform's policy
i'm not going to read his quote because
you know even though i know you already
did but
then they might try i'll tell you what i
do when i read quotes i'll do this
quote i share some caution on this
vaccine because we
and this is mark zuckerberg saying this
just don't know the long term and again
mark zuckerberg
side effects of basically and again this
is from mark zuckerberg's quote
modifying people's dna mark zuckerberg
here and rna
no no i have to do that because they'll
selectively edit yes
yes no joke no joke me reading something
from mark zuckerberg and they will
splice it together well
go ahead and splice it that many times
if you really want to do it some people
will
but this is mark zuckerberg basically
saying something that as far as i can
tell
was never believed to be correct when
when the when when the research in the
news was coming about coming out about
the mrna vaccine
it was never true it was always a
conspiracy theory
that it modified dna now at the time it
was not against facebook's rules to
claim that that's my understanding
that's correct right
at the time but recently facebook
announced that they are quote
expanding their efforts to remove false
claims on facebook about
the vaccine so mark zuckerberg makes the
statement in july
where he's essentially violating
facebook's own policy and the question
is
i guess mark zuckerberg's thinking has
evolved on the vaccine
and but it's a little bit strange
because
he's now just instituted this policy
prohibiting
what he was saying a few months ago
well i think it's fair to say people's
opinions change
and mark zuckerberg was clearly wrong in
this
the mrna it essentially it doesn't
change your dna
it just configures certain cells to
produce the spike protein
and then when those cells die off that's
it that's the end of it that's why
there's actually multiple doses that's
why they say
it doesn't work necessarily in the long
term but this was i don't know what he
was reading
mark zuckerberg was reading fake news
now it's fine
in my opinion that he wants to have an
opinion that's incorrect because people
are wrong even mark zuckerberg
the real issue here as you can see and
uh and we were talking about this
earlier
zuckerberg has afforded the right to
pontificate on things that were widely
considered to be conspiracy theories at
the time right whereas if i said the
same thing i would have been annihilated
in the media
he's telling his own staffers this stuff
now he's implementing this rule and
again i'm not holding against him that
he changes opinion
okay but the authority is him this is
the problem
who appointed mark zuckerberg to decide
when and how we're allowed to think
about things and share opinions well his
own vice president nick
clegg we had him on a leak tape
basically saying they're just making
this stuff up as they go
this is nick clegg vice president of
facebook he's a british guy and he's
on the i guess he has their own
oversight board
and and they're basically playing the
role of judge and jury of the supreme
court
the financial times reported there is a
growing trend tech companies think they
should be
deciding public policy not government
and this is a prime example
this has nothing to do with my opinion
about the vaccine or whatever or europe
it doesn't the point is zuckerberg is
the ceo of facebook
and just a couple months ago he was
anti-vaxx
this is mark zuckerberg not me not you
not us it's mark
zuckerberg the ceo of maybe the most
powerful company in the history of the
planet earth
at a time when if you tweeted anything
remotely anti-vaxx
they went after you hard but this is the
ceo of facebook anti-vaxx
on the record not on the record he's off
the record he's but he's closed doors
to a major i guess he's on the record to
his own staff
is his own executive committee saying
this this is a whistleblower inside
facebook
folks has given us this tape of mark
zuckerberg that is one of mark's own
colleagues
is a source to james o'keefe and is
still
a source to james o'keefe that's why
those engineers are very careful right
now
pretty cool pretty cool right and mark
zuckerberg just a few months ago said
i'm anti-vaxx
i think it changes your dna again mark
zuckerberg's words not mine
it's too late they gotcha but suddenly
now mark zuckerberg has changed the
policy you're not allowed to even
pontificate
about the vaccine doesn't that seem a
little capricious to you
i think i think it's it's it's good that
he finally realized he was wrong i think
this is actually included in your report
that he he did a public conversation
with dr phil
and here's what i love about this
because i texted you when i saw this and
i was like
well look i get it if you change his
opinion you guys fully included the
dates of when he said it
the date of when he had a change of
opinion you're not hiding the fact that
and i think it's fair to point out that
sometimes people's opinions change and
good good for mark zuckerberg on
realizing he was wrong
the issue is if it's wrong to say it now
we knew it was wrong to say it at
you know back in july when he was
telling his employees this the point is
why was the rule just implemented why
was mark zuckerberg allowed to push
insane conspiracy theories to a massive
company facebook
just it's i guess the idea is if we're
going to live under this rule about
disinformation
you can clearly see that mark zuckerberg
shares this information
and then it only changes when he
realizes he was spreading his name
in many ways and and and this nick clegg
the vice president of facebook is
admitting
as much in in a leaked tape one of these
leaked tapes
saying we're kind of we're kind of
having to come up with these rules think
of it like the us constitution imagine
the united states constitution had
very specific things that you're not
allowed to say
one of them is you cannot speak about
the coveted vaccine i mean that's what
facebook is saying they're just making
new things up that you can't talk about
and the analogy i draw is the
constitution of the united states is
very clear
congress shall make no law prohibiting
the free exercise of the freedom of
speech but facebook has these rules
about
certain subjects you're not allowed to
pontificate about
and and the audience well they're
they're a private company they can say
what they want
their private i get their private
company but you can't
lie lying is wrong it's just unethical
i would even question the private uh you
know remark there because
they work hand in hand with the
government in many different ways so
that would say they're even a quasi
government agency not even from their
seed funding but from what they're doing
now
so it's interesting because i mean he's
afforded to change his mind he's allowed
he's allowed to pontificate but but
we're not
you know that's the thing when you when
you get rid of conversation when you
censor it when you stifle it
you spread a lot of these crazier
theories and then again it
deserves to be called out but i'm happy
someone's calling look at twitter
and hunter biden the this is one of the
biggest media scandals
of our generation a new story broke
about hunter biden
vice president joe well now president
joe biden's son at the time
running for the the highest office in
the land and his son was implicated in
some very serious crimes and his brother
so twitter intervened facebook
intervened and they publicly bragged
don't worry
we are suppressing this story so people
can't see it
and then what two weeks after the
election was over they were like oh that
story that was true the whole time
it was true the whole time that is
horrifying
and so this goes hand in hand uh i think
you're looking for some consistency the
consistency would be
mark zuckerberg says don't spread
disinformation we derank this
information
they give power to these third-party
fact-checking organizations which
just make stuff up and they put out fake
news themselves like my favorite was
snopes article did ocasio-cortez
exaggerate the danger she experienced in
the capital
false while she wasn't in the capital
the capital was stormed
no aoc's story about the capital
took place a full hour and 10 minutes
before the building had been breached
so i think it is fair to have the
opinion she exaggerated
why then is snopes given the ability to
slap a warning label
on my posts which is in my opinion
they didn't actually do that to me i'm
just saying on on your or anyone else's
post
snopes can now put their opinion over
your opinion
if we're supposed to be living by a
standard to stop disinformation
i think what we've now realized from you
know the the video you've put out just
now
this is the context i think you need to
make sure people understand right that
in july it was a conspiracy theory
to say what mark zuckerberg was saying
and he didn't care he let people say it
now he had the epiphany so he makes the
rule
that's the problem are we allowed to
have these ideas and communicate or is
it only on mark zuckerberg's whims the
rules change
i mean this is an extraordinary point
tim i mean
it's like a constitution people need to
understand these companies just
okay now we're going to create a rule
this week saying you're not allowed to
talk about this
these are private companies again this
is from the financial times momentous
decisions in the hands of private
companies is not a long-term
public policy solution they neither have
the legitimacy nor the capacity
to make such decisions in the public
interest these are supreme court these
are akin to
supreme court decisions for facebook to
say
okay now you are not allowed to talk
about vaccines it will ban you it's it's
more powerful than if the united states
supreme court were to cast a decision
tomorrow saying
you are not allowed to talk about red
delicious
so hold on is the rule actually that you
can't talk about vaccines at all or i'm
going to read the rule to you this is
last week mario i believe that
this is facebook announced last week a
new rule that said quote
we are expanding efforts to remove false
claims on facebook and instagram about
coved vaccines and vaccines in
general so i wonder you know be really
funny if like one day
mark zuckerberg just like he meets
somebody who he
this epiphany and he becomes this crazy
fruitarian who thinks meat is wrong
right and then he passes a rule where
he's like i think that
eating meat is just wrong and eating
vegetables is also wrong you know
a lot of people talk about not doing
harm to animals but you also harm the
plant when you eat the vegetable
fruits are actually meant to be eaten so
i think everyone should have to eat
nothing but fruit and spread the seeds
so now we're going to ban anyone who
promotes meat or advertises it
that's exactly right right that's
exactly what he's insane because in july
he said no this thing is
i'm an anti-vaxx guy and i think it
modifies your dna this is like not
five ten years ago this was in 2020 he
said this
and suddenly he had a change of heart i
mean so i i think that
facebook is more powerful than the
united states supreme court in fact
these tech
companies are powerful all three
branches of government so when they make
when they make a rule change that says
you can't talk about something
it's it's as if the united states
supreme court
made a change about codified the united
states constitution
give me the ability to control what
people say and i care not who makes the
law well the thing
is okay this is the big debate this is
it there's a big debate of our times
they're they're private companies right
now
and we don't have the right to seize
their means of production
as a company that's that's very
communist if we were to say okay
facebook now you're government
controlled
we're taking the country we're not going
to do that we're not seeing all the
means so we're not going to make them
create their own terms of service we
can't do that that's a communistic
takeover we can't do that listen to me
and
the problem is these companies have a
right to create their own terms
as as does a restaurant they don't want
you talking about certain things in the
restaurant get out of the restaurant
that's the restaurant owner's right
my concern is how do we move forward in
the society with that
still being the case and i can only find
tim please let me finish this thought
that we need to free the software code
it's the only way
to allow other people to create software
as powerful as facebook
with their own terms of service so you
made several points there and the
premise
of your final conclusion is incorrect
which is what i'm trying to address
scale exists if there is one person
buying up
all the farmland and now no one has food
the people have a right to say
nah you can't do that one small plot of
farmland has a right to their
sovereignty to grow their crops and be
left alone
one person seizing every single
opportunity for people to eat
is very different facebook is not some
small platform people use sometimes
it is the one of the largest if not it
is the second largest website i think on
the planet behind google
and they essentially control the flow of
information by by monopolizing it
they've now used that monopoly power to
control our politics
it is not the same thing as a restaurant
there's 50 different restaurants that
are not chains i can go to
there's no other facebook the president
is not on these other platforms okay i
agree
it is a monopoly but if you look at
rockefeller standard oil
they broke it up that was the first
monopoly and all it did was make
rockefeller more rich
they created six new oil companies that
he had stock in all six so if they did
this to facebook
you'd have facebook prime you'd have
facebook messenger you couldn't have
installed the answer and zuck
no it's not the answer breaking up
facebook regulating it by freeing the
software code yes
why would bring the software code doing
it because it would give people the
opportunity to create software as
powerful
with their own terms and then people
would migrate to the place with the best
terms
you just advocated against seizing the
means of production now you're
advocating for it
no i think that facebook has a right to
function and i would never want to take
it away from marketing the code is their
means of production the music production
is the website
no the factory is yes what's what's the
website made of the code right
yeah so you want to give the secret
sauce that makes their system work yeah
but i'm not going to take their system
that's what you're advocating no i'm not
taking i don't want to take facebook i
want to
free the software code so other people
can create more of them
so you're taking it's different they're
allowed to keep their brand but not the
actual
and the website and all the marketing
that goes through the web yes of course
that's that's the only the in my that's
the only capitalist
solution i can find over the last two
years we're talking about transparency
i mean these are these are these are
these platforms uh
they have the ability to amplify certain
voices while excluding others
it's a product of you know scale
economies and and their power comes from
from squeezing out al alternative
platforms
while fueling this virality and and i
think i mean i agree with you on one
hand i think it's about
transparency i i'm biased veritas my
mission i believe in it
if we just expose how they do what they
do you're talking about like
letting their competitors know how how
what do you mean by
by showing their what they're doing
access to the source code access to the
code so you can see what the how
the algorithms work um how the code is
built how the software is built
so you could reuse it and if you make it
a free software code if you take the
software and change it make it better
they would have access to your changes
as well
interesting interesting
i don't know i think the the answer is
you know we had uh
will chamberlain on the show talking
about how parlor isn't the answer
we need platform access as a civil right
to make sure people have the ability to
use these platforms
but i got to be honest the problem is
multi-faceted so i'll give you one
example
just because i'm allowed to use twitter
does that mean twitter is functioning
properly
right so we talk about facebook
censorship and the capriciousness of
their rule changes well
recently i quote tweeted cassandra
fairbanks she was talking about she did
this story about vans pulling up to the
tcf center
and questions being raised about it i
said i didn't think the videos mattered
whatever they do prove or don't prove
i don't think they matter because time
magazine wrote an article basically
saying that uh
you know the election was rigged and
then i put i'm sorry they didn't say it
was rigged they say it was fortified by
changing election laws and
manipulating the flow of information
that's a fact they didn't say it was
rigged that's what i said they said it
was fortified
time magazine or this article twitter
blocked
my tweet in all forms you can't retweet
it you can't quote you can't respond you
can't no i'm sorry you can't quote you
can't respond
retweet or like and they put a tag
saying this claim about fraud is
disputed
but it's literally not disputed time
magazine wrote it i was quoting time
magazine
so i actually reached out to jack and i
said could you remove this it is a false
statement of fact
jack did not respond but he responds
sometimes you know i talk to him
every so often thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you